今年是36岁，
然后我老公是42岁，
我们是结婚十年了，
有两个小孩，
现在是有一套房，
但是这个房是抵押的，
因为他是做生意的，
是抵押贷款的有300个，
我个人的话有100个。
有两台车，
一台是抵押的，
另一台是按揭，
都是在公司名下，
然后这个公司是经营的，
有10年没什么利润那种，
然后我们现在也是没有存款的，
现在公司那边就是房租也是拖欠了几个月，
工资也是发不出来的那种状态，
我是在二宝半岁的时候吧，
就发现他有出，
后面又有发现有批。
之前都是原谅的过，
一直过下来，
然后今年4月份的时候，
我就发现他跟女下属有那种关系嘛，
有时候去出差干嘛的，
带他去玩啊，
干嘛发现之后呢，
他说也是会改的，
承诺的好好的，
但是后面又发现还是在联系，
还是有这种关系的，
因为这个事有今年都已经吵过两三次的，
甚至他他们又出去了，
然后就会被我发现有那个还记录。
我就是不想，
不想再这样过下去了，
所以我要想情帮我分析一下，
嗯，
现在你们的状态是虽然有一套房，
但是抵押贷款了300多万，
然后呢，
这两个车也是在公司名下，
公司又没有利润，
然后其他你们也没有存款，
是这样一个状态，
对吧？
嗯，
是的，
那你娘家是干什么的呢？
有一家是农村的，
你帮过这么忙，
那这两个孩子你有什么安排呀，
将来呀，
你自己就是这些年是主要带孩子还是说自己也在挣钱呀，
我是之前是带孩子，
然后孩子大的时候就在公司做财务。
嗯，
现在我们就算一笔总账吧，
现在人整个家庭的资产是负债大于资产，
是资不抵债的状态，
你你觉得你的老公这些年啊，
混成资不抵债，
主要原因是什么？
没有选对行业，
还是他能力有问题啊，
还是啥？
他说他自己现在也也一直在努力，
但是就是没赚到多钱，
那没赚到什么钱，
你觉得是他性格原因啊，
能力问题啊，
还是说。
客观的外界的原因导致的呢，
这能力应该也有关系吧，
然后现在市场也不景气，
嗯，
他又给别人花大钱吗？
没有，
他现在可能，
嗯，
手里没什么钱，
那这种情况下，
假设要是分开了，
你怎么过呢？
我是想自己过，
然后还把小孩给他，
小孩给他了之后。
那怎么办呢？
谁带小孩呢？
他自己现在不是有公司吗？
就是让他自己去请阿姨干嘛的哦，
他他是对自己，
他是说很有信心。
曹若博，
一直这样下去，
就是公司那假设啊，
因为你今年也36岁了啊，
自从这段婚姻里面出来了之后，
现在这个状态的话，
不仅仅分不到钱，
还有可能分到债务是不是？
那你好好的人生，
你打算怎么办呢？
债务的话，
我我觉得应该可以，
就是说让他自己承担，
他应该也会同意吧，
老师应该是他就是挽留，
他不想让我走啊，
你你在公司做财务做了多少年了，
我是这两年才开始做的，
以前是学这个专业，
但是就带小孩子就没有做，
是你凭你的感觉，
你确定是家里面是资不抵债呢，
还是说他有可能转移了一部分钱？
没有了，
没有就是那种负债的状态，
这俩孩子你能舍得吗？
孩子都给他了，
都给我，
那我自己也带不了啊，
我如果要去上班的话，
我觉得像你们这种情况，
就算你这么选择的话，
也无可厚非啊，
也没有人能就是说。
指责你，
因为你也是无奈了，
没办法了，
面对这样一个资不抵债的状况，
面对这样一个能力又不咋地的老公，
且还在外面东搞西搞的，
对呀，
他现在是又准备也要去贷，
要去贷款，
你签字吗？
他贷款应该是要签的，
我觉得你现在就别签了吧，
最好是有一个离什么什么证，
能把能把你剥离出来，
能让你别上黑名单，
也承担风险，
但是他那些这些不是已经借了那么多的嘛，
如果还不人都会，
你也是两个人都会有意，
如果还不都是要进黑名单的吧，
如果你都签了字了的话，
是还不了的话要进黑名单的，
对呀，
你不能说因为我以前签过，
所以我现在再签一点吧，
你不能这么想问题啊，
就是以前签的这些，
你毕竟还有房产抵押呢，
你毕竟还有一定的资产，
是可以抵得住一部分的，
对不对，
那你现在再多签一点的话，
那可能就真的是没有回头路了，
我是想着如果这个钱下来，
然后让他分点给我，
然后我拿出来我就走了，
他愿意吗？
你的意思是你去签一个贷款，
然后他分点给你，
你拿着钱走是吧？
对呀，
我就去还钱，
那也不债务，
他将来要是还不了的话，
那你怎么搞嘞？
那我这个钱如果他给到我，
我自己把它转移掉的话，
你只要给了心的，
给了新的，
万一实在将来不行的话，
你就上黑名单，
完了之后你就用现金，
是这意思，
不，
这是最坏的结果。
所以这事我。
不能在直播间支持你啊，
但是我觉得你想的也很通透了，
也不是说不可行，
举个例子，
如果说能有50万的现金在手上，
最起码不影响你的生活嘛，
但是我不能在直播间鼓励你这么干啊，
鼓励你这么干是不对的，
嗯，
那如果是跟他的就不签这个贷款，
然后直接跟他分开写那个协议里面，
然后写那个补偿款，
然后那个分月给的话，
那种可以吗？
是可以的，
就比如说你们在离婚协议里面就这么写，
说这个房子的价值是300万，
是我们母妻共同财产，
那个离婚的话，
我们一人一半，
男方应该给你150万，
好，
男方给你是150万的话，
分几年给几月几号给多少万，
这个是可以的，
你最好在离婚协议里面要写清楚啊，
就是这个债务是因为男方的生意周转，
然后女方配合签的字，
所以这个债务的话由男方偿还，
这意思，
那你的建议是分开给他是吧，
我感觉你这个分不分其实没多大意义，
因为没有钱，
你知道吧，
跟那个女的也是我，
我觉得他应该也是不会这么快就断的，
那个女的也是蠢，
他要找的话，
找了一个负债累累的人也是蠢的，
要不你你左边看，
主要是你们现在是资不抵债的状态，
那个女的也是蠢的，
也得不到什么好处，
但是得不到什么东西，
但是如果说从保护你个人的角度。
来说的话，
我觉得有一个协议，
有一个证，
对你来说也是一种保护，
然后以后你不用跟他在一起去签什么协议了，
他在欠债跟你也没什么关系了，
嗯，
现谢你很好，
刚刚有个人问了，
说净身出户行不行，
这个东西因为你签了那个，
你跟他共同去签的那个贷款，
就算你这头净身出户的话，
你共同签的那个贷款也没办法，
也是在身上的，
他明白这是两个不同的法律关系，
一个法律关系是两口子，
对银行只要你去签了那个字了，
那银行就得找你们两口子了，
哪怕说你，
我说我净身出户了啊，
我一毛都不要了，
但这个债务也躲不掉，
明白这里面的利害关系了吧。
所以他这个。
要么就是铁了心了，
我就黑名单，
我就不管破摔，
我就用现金啊，
我就是就还不了就债了，
那就没办法，
要么呢，
就是期待着说她老公将来可能生意好做一点，
商业环境好一点，
能把这个啊贷款给还上，
这样的话，
最起码在这段婚姻当中没有背债。
有的时候我想想外面那个女的我都不明白她对吧，
找这么个男的，
又有两个孩子，
又没离婚，
又欠那么多债，
可能外面那个女的以为这男的有钱吧，
我感觉还有人说可能他们是真爱吧，
你说这个世界上为什么会有那么多女的稀里糊涂的呢？
为什么会这样呢？
有的时候我爱了自己啊，
干这行干那么久了，
我也琢琢磨琢磨，
脑仁儿就疼这么多女的选老公的时候，
选伴侣的时候，
怎么就这么草率呢？
不就人家送你回家啊，
给你披件衣裳，
一瞬间心里就扑通扑通扑通就不行了，
就沦陷了，
人家给你夹个菜，
表现的对你关心一点，
给你打个酒话，
心里面又不行了，
又扑通扑通又冒泡泡了，
怎么那么容易就喜欢上一个男人呢？
这一天天的，
可能就是这些电视剧一天天演的，
那电视剧你从高楼上来，
有个男主角抱着你转个圈圈又不行了，
哎，
经对人动情了啊，
看到男的骑个马从你身边经过，
长得帅一点，
哎呀，
心里又不。
啊，
又开始动心了，
又看到人家是把射箭射的好啊，
一下子就射到那个什么眉心了，
射到你心巴上了就不行了，
又怎么那么容易就喜欢一个人呢？